hello IMAX movie goes hey IMAX fans I'm
gonna show you something
[Music]
Showtime a-holes
[Music]
I max is just a completely immersive
viewing experience the aspect ratio is
probably more well suited for Marvel
losing us for anything because there's a
lot of verticality of character I max up
close as the greatest thing ever because
the frame disappears to fill more of the
screen
exclusively for IMAX this is maybe
sometimes you just want to hang out on
my face 60 feet wide on an IMAX screen
that's what having TV screens smashed
into your face I love watching my
favorite way to watch food there are
sequences it is amazing that you will
not see the full experience unless you
see it in time
[Music]
it's the spectrum is the objective these
sorts of movies size matters
the sound is incredible
the colors they're so rich this film is
best appreciated in an I'm mentoring you
just want to stand in front of it and
off
a lot of superheroes coming together
it's dramatic and powerful
sounds like the IMAX was the appropriate
call damn right
[Music]
[Music]
you